[Music]
hey conan it's billy eichner i am out
here in indianapolis it is the weekend
of the super bowl everyone here in town
is more concerned with the game but i'm
talking about the celebrities and all
the parties that are happening going to
hit the streets and see what everyone
thinks about madonna and all the other
celebrities in town let's go sir are you
excited about madonna i'm very excited
about madonna yeah
big show i know right yeah performing
with her yeah nicki minaj nicki minaj
that's m.i.a really yeah all right oh
god sir sir are you excited about
madonna very excited very excited more
excited about winning the super bowl for
the patriots i don't care about that how
are you i'm gonna put it again yes
are you excited about madonna
no i'm excited about the giants being
here no i don't care about the giants
i'm here for madonna oh yeah but donna i
like her i've heard her music i like her
too yeah she's an icon yes yeah what
about nicki minaj
yeah
yeah i've heard that love music too yeah
kelly clarkson's here i know
yes that's exciting yes a lot of
celebrities in town yes yeah howie
mandela oh my god
yes you're excited about the super bowl
yes yes
about madonna um what get out of here
miss giselle's in town
gisele's in town gisele's in town sir
are you excited about
madonna yeah
now it is the day of the super bowl it
is super bowl sunday i'm out here right
near lucas oil stadium people are
tailgating we're going to go inside see
what people think about madonna let's go
you're excited about madonna absolutely
yes what's your favorite madonna song
material girl that's a good one
you excited about madonna so excited
yeah who's better madonna lady gaga
madonna thank you you're classic yes
thank you
makes you excited about madonna i'm so
excited yes me too can't wait to see
what she has in store be great yeah so
do you know where i can get any coke
oh okay sorry
[Applause]
apparently it's only a half hour more
till madonna
just gotta get through some of this
first damn patching how are you why are
you yelling because it's very loud
madonna's playing soon
it's not that loud i can hear you okay
fine are you excited about madonna yes
okay fine good
happy super bowl
what does that mean what do you mean is
there a card we're a happy superman i
don't care i'm excited about madonna i
just found out first i have to play some
terrible terrible game yelling okay
goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
conan it's billy i'm on the field the
halftime show is done they're clearing
us out
madonna was amazing and she had cello on
two
she had celo2 what a night for tiny arms
and the new york giants
given the last rights by many in
december are the super bowl champs in
february conan's billy
the game just ended
madonna was amazing i'm on the field
conan
i'm gonna talk to the players about
madonna kelly clarkson
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god
vogue mother
what an amazing night
what a great night i'm on the same field
where madonna performed congratulations
man appreciate it mantis you guys played
an amazing game it's something that was
hard fought for man you know we knew
that it wasn't going to be easy yeah
them coming out here and playing the way
they did taking my head out to him and
you know i'm just loving it right now
baby congratulations did you guys see
madonna
do you guys see madonna
hey did you see madonna no oh she's
amazing i was in the locker room okay
signing off from the field of the super
bowl it's been an amazing weekend an
amazing night congratulations to the new
york giants congratulations to madonna
and it's going to be team coco all the
way in 2013. see you next time
that was really great